the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media i want to tell you about the night
pass nation tour kicks off this weekend
y'all phoenix september 16th through the
18th all right and then we're going to
keep on rolling indy i'll be seeing you
all september 30th through october 2nd
baltimore coming home saturday october
23rd brea headline in october 28th
arlington virginia november 12th and
13th cleveland ohio december 9th through
the 11th la jolla california december
17th through the 19th i'll be in austin
texas january 6 to the 8th and kansas
city
in uh january 20th through the 22nd look
there's more dates okay they're all
there there's a lot more being added
we're coming a lot of places not as many
as toms agora's not quite everywhere but
coming some places with tom segura too
so go check out ryan sickler.com sign up
for the newsletter you'll be the first
to know all the stuff going on and the
youtube thank you for your support on
the honeydew thank you for your support
of this show
uh if you watch and you love the show
and you want to help out do something
free subscribe to the show yo that's all
you got to do and the patreon
we are we just talked to a guy again i'm
going to keep talking about this this
guy solved an 18 year old cold case okay
stepped on a stick [ __ ] rock rolls
over and it's a skull looking at the
dude bullet hole between the eyes
bullets still in the goddamn skull and
they [ __ ] solve an 18 year old cold
case ain't no show out there like like
the honey do with y'all right now all
right so if you or someone you know has
a story that has to be her please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
subscribe today you don't need to be a
subscriber to submit your story all
right but if you subscribe and you know
you're in for the long haul i want to
help you out you can save over a month
of free episodes by signing up for a
year you get audio and video you get the
entire back catalog and you get the
honeydew a day early ad-free
at no additional cost all right i do
know that that five bucks a month is a
lot for some people and you can do
better things with it but if you got it
and you want to hear these stories
please subscribe all right you know
where to get the merch everything's at
ryancicler.com the ringtones you guys
want to ringtones in my laugh they're
there go to ryansickler.com we're
working on getting them for uh android
now on the website all right now that is
the information i wanted to tell you i
can't wait for real though i cannot wait
to come out and see you guys on tour
i've sat here in this little room for
the last year and a half with your
support and uh we grew a little we built
a small little army and i want to come
see you guys and i can't wait so thank
you this is a gratitude tour more than
anything
now you all know we do here we highlight
the lowlights these are the stories
behind the storytellers i'm very excited
to have today's storyteller here with us
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
raylen nelson y'all welcome to the
honeydew hi ryan thanks for having me
you're very welcome you're very welcome
you're the most best i appreciate it um
i'm very excited to have you here we've
we've met through comedy which i love
yeah um me too big fan you are willie
nelson's granddaughter yes and you have
your own band your own music you got
your own thing going on in nashville so
why don't you before we get into
anything here just plug it all promote
it all okay so
how i met you was through music is funny
podcast which my guitar player and i
started over coveting you and jb yeah jb
uh also my music partner and um you know
we were bored and we when we were on the
road before kovid we didn't agree on the
music that we listened to in the van on
road trip so we would just listen to
comedy
podcasts
uh stand up we would just pull up
specials
so over covid we were like well let's
just see if they'll you know talk to us
and
everybody's starting a podcast so we
might as well
and so we just tried and of course
i loved it the way you guys got
the comics that you like to talk to it's
just by starting a podcast it works yeah
i've got a lot of podcasts for people
that i did one for a kid i'm doing
another one for a 13 year old kid like
if i'm free i'll do it you know what i
mean i love it that's who i am yeah
i just did one for a couple of kids too
and it was awesome they
they were the hosts of it yeah that's
this kid is too yeah i did one for a kid
to host and then there's a 13 year old
kid i'm doing or 14 i'm doing his coming
up yeah he's the host and you're working
with kids teaching them yeah i teach the
um outreach to the arts kids here and
then i teach the culver city high school
high school kids podcasting at the other
store here at the santa monica music
here at the santa monica music center
owned by lana negrete yeah i love lana
so much you've been hanging out with us
all weekend you're like hey ryan nice to
meet you we're period sisters that's
ridiculous
she made me start my period 13 days
early it was the weirdest [ __ ] thing
we hung out for three days never met
before
never met your period's sake
so glad i'm a dude every [ __ ] day i'm
so glad
ash i'll tell you by now our periods
definitely would have been synced bro
it should be done by now we should be
able to click something that says okay
we don't want kids anymore we're done
anyway i love lana so much
um
yeah and you've had josh wolfe on your
show you've had jason alice on your show
i've done your show who else have you
had kathleen madigan yeah i love
kathleen i did too she's awesome we've
actually um gone out drinking having a
couple beers together uh and jody her
manager is awesome uh let's see who else
doug stanhope did we say that tom papa i
mean man you're getting killers aries
yeah you're getting killers that's great
all right i just actually got an email
from ari today asking if i could hook
him up with some weed and shrooms for
bonnaroo
[Laughter]
and i'm just so happy that he reached
out to me to ask he's asking you for
wean shrooms and i'm like just please
get willie nelson to take a picture of
my night pants with a joint please with
a joint and in my night pants i'll just
take the night picture i'm going to make
it happen yeah i just oh my god if
willie nelson's a night pants nation are
you [ __ ] out of here i mean jeez i'll
[ __ ] myself
i have to get new night pants girl
um what's your social media all that
stuff
i thought you were into social security
which is so sh
what's your social security number 196.
um okay so raylynn nelson band and um
app music is funny but i just put
everything on ray and nelson band cause
we have some followers there
yeah and um
check out my band too you know it's on
you can check it on spotify and youtube
we have a bunch of music videos that we
made that nobody's seen so check them
out
on our youtube channel
i am i just look i want to say thank you
and i'm also super flattered this is one
of my top fav favorite comedy podcasts i
can't believe i'm even friends with you
i don't even know what you're saying
just don't even know what you're doing
and i didn't even um i didn't fan girl
out on you yet and we've been hanging
out for the past couple days and you
took me to the [ __ ] comedy store how
fun was that it was so much fun and
every every single person on the lineup
was great thank you emily thanks emily
i didn't get to talk to her very much
and she was serious she looks so
serious yeah she is she's running that
[ __ ] yeah no joke and she sat up there
while you guys the whole everyone did
the show
and um i didn't i didn't see any kind of
you know what was going on but um she
was in it and listening and laughing and
into it isn't that [ __ ] great to see
like someone's really invested in you
know watching people still and not just
putting [ __ ] on autopilot and you know
and it's interesting that you i know
you're an entertainer you're an artist
so you see that i love that you picked
that up yeah she sits there i tell
everybody like she's the whole time
there's no throwing a camera up and i'll
watch this [ __ ] later she's there that's
more pressure for sure you know so
um but yeah that was a killer [ __ ]
show seems like she's trying to do it
right
um
but i've always had this thing so when
you said i totally get it because we're
the same way comics are the same way
like i want let's listen to music you
know what i mean like we we hear all
this [ __ ] all the same right it's the
opposite
and um
i've always like i'm so flattered that
you guys listen to my comedy on your bus
and [ __ ] that there's this you know the
jackson brown song um where he's talking
about they're out on the road stay it's
staying he's talking about we got uh
what does he say we got um
we got truckers on seabees we got
richard pryor on the video and i've
always [ __ ] just loved
it's it's this it's stuck with me like
it's true man these [ __ ] guys are top
musicians in the world and they're out
on the road watching
richard pryor and back then they must
have had a laser disc up in that [ __ ]
but i don't know what they had a vhs in
that bus or something but i was like man
how [ __ ] cool is that so then for you
to say that i'm like
what a simulation
well
my grandpa's always been a big fan of
comedy he was friends with richard pryor
and you said i i forgot he's in the
comedy store doc that you were watching
yeah
yeah uh this it feels like a comedy trip
this time because i did i've watched the
i found the e true hollywood story of it
on vimeo some random vimeo and then uh
yeah watch the comedy store doc and then
papa willie shows up there and i guess
sally fields was there that same day and
i don't know princess diana was but it
kind of seemed like that but it could
have been a different day and
but anyway it seemed like a uh
yeah my grandpa loved richard pryor and
my aunt amy and my grandmother or my
step-grandmother connie who i was named
after actually my first name is
constance oh you're constantly she's
friends with jennifer
or no yes constance raylan nelson that's
my name i'm sorry so she's friends with
her with jennifer pryor oh okay
so i've never talked to her but they
talk to her regularly so i definitely
obviously we want to hear some of those
stories but let's go back to the
beginning for you because your your dad
is willie nelson's son yeah willie
nelson jr but everyone called him billy
okay
and
where are they originally from like
where did your parents meet and grow up
and okay so
my dad was on the bus with papa willie
and rode through town in nashville my
mom was working at a radio station as
one of those promo girls how old was
your dad
20
21 and your mom's what same
okay so he was probably 23 or 24 because
she was 20 21 and he's out on the road
with [ __ ] willie nelson yeah he he
was 16 years old when my grandpa made it
big can you imagine being 16 years old
and your grandpa's or your dad is the
biggest thing on the planet
i mean this is what we talked about you
gave me this shirt and i wore it
straight up out of respect but there's
famous and then there's [ __ ] iconic
and
there's no one that wouldn't see this
and not know that's [ __ ] willie
nelson right you know what i mean like
it's crazy so
i no i couldn't imagine being especially
sixteen like think of it you're young
and dumb and [ __ ] wanna probably put
your dick in every [ __ ] thing out
there and you're seeing like a world
that isn't even realistic
and uh i mean i'm just being honest i'm
just glad he stuck his dick in my mom
you know
thanks mom for opening up
you did the right thing yeah you did
good so they're on uh on a promotional
tour and they meet yeah and my dad was
uh he always wore cowboy [ __ ] you know i
think that was in at the time but he
wanted to be a cowboy
um other than comedy my grandpa loves
western so he would throw those up on
the on the tv and the bus too
so chaps my dad was wearing chaps in the
summertime just weird you know it's so
weird he had to be charismatic and good
looking as [ __ ] though yeah he would
wear chaps and still land a lady i feel
like he was handsome my grandma was
beautiful she was full-blooded cherokee
indian and he took a lot after her
um anyway so they met meet they fall in
love they get married very quickly
and they have me and then they get
divorced
how how fast i was three when they got
divorced are you their only child okay
you are yeah that i that i know right
you know but i don't think
we don't think he was
no who knows you know but i don't think
so so by 23 now your dad's a single dad
yeah and your mom's a single mom same
age
and when he was young my grandpa was
trying to make it in the music business
so he
was with
his mom and then he'd be with his
stepmoms depending on who the stepmom
was at the time and
so he didn't get a lot of time with my
grandpa or his dad you know right so i
don't know that he was ever shown how to
be a dad right
but uh but he wasn't around much i know
he was really into some you know the hot
drugs at the time
cocaine and a lot of liquor a lot of
uppity stuff but
hard liquor i think he smoked weed all
day long you know did you um my grandpa
tried to get him into rehab a couple
times and
uh
it didn't ever you know it never worked
so you're living with mom
mostly living with mom saying dad when
it was safe mostly when and so was that
when they would come to town or
something like that
he lived in nashville you know in a town
called ridge top
and my mom did too and she did hair and
we just lived in the in the salon she
still owns that house and rinse it out
nah that's awesome yeah it's cool
uh
and she actually taught me that i bought
real estate really young
because you know she taught me hey you
can
if you own real estate it's a pretty
good way to you know make money unless
you're
a celebrity of some kind anyway
uh so i would see my dad but he was i
never i don't ever remember going off
with him without her being there
and whenever papa willie came through
town of course we were there even after
my dad
my dad's passing my mom always took me
so
my mom
my mom turned into a holy roller about
that time
and uh
so wait your dad what happened to your
dad your dad died okay wait
okay they get divorced my mom turns into
a holy roller
she's praying for a new husband she
meets
like out loud
oh yeah
yes wow out loud out loud
that's gotta be weird to be walking
around a friend of mine was telling me
a friend of mine was telling me some um
some like embarrassing stories about her
mom the other day and i was like oh my
god the only thing i was scared my mom
would do was speak in tongues over my
friends in high school so i wouldn't let
them come around her would she do that
i was well i told her like mom i don't
want you to speak in tongues over them
she's like i wouldn't do that i'm like
if you thought god told you to you would
and she was like yeah yeah
wait no i'm not what made her shift into
this holy roller was she always
religious or was it a 180 okay so it was
the full no
she was walking up and down dickerson
road and a playboy bunny outfit trying
to get into a club when she was a
teenager
she was not i love you mom
but she confessed her sins to our lord
and savior jesus christ
and he forgives us all you know so
and
she's dedicated her life to ministry and
she does nothing but help people and
pray for them and
helps me and has always been there for
me and we're super tight and i tease her
all the time okay good she taught me to
be a good person you know so
and she at that time she was into not
lying so she taught me about not lying
very early on
she told me santa claus wasn't real when
i was four and a half she was like i
feel bad that i've lied to you about
this
and she had me because
okay do you remember do you remember the
simpsons of course okay well i wasn't
allowed to watch the simpsons no i don't
know anything about it for you my mom
wouldn't let me watch it she was just
kind of kept me pretty sheltered
and so
because this was around that holy roller
time and so i remember one christmas
waking up and there was that whoever
what's the little sisters and babies
name the little baby okay there was that
doll there and i was like
and i look at my mom i'm like santa
claus brought this samson doll she was
like i can't believe he did that like
acting mad so i really believe santa
claus was real right and then like a
month later she's like
um god
god has laid it on my heart
listen rylan
this other imaginary [ __ ] is telling
me to tell you that this other imaginary
[ __ ] i've been telling you about is
[ __ ]
amen
[Laughter]
i am like five four or five years old
like that's me so heavy for a [ __ ]
four-year-old
i mean all of it
and i and you know it's me and my mom
you know so i'm like okay and she's like
we're not gonna lie anymore there's no
tooth fairy there's no easter bunny
there's no oh she unloaded it
not one of them
looking back i should have been like is
there a god you know yeah all right hey
hold on no
that one's real yeah that's fake one's
right
not the tooth fairy not the easter bunny
who else is out there who else did you
all have in your childhood what do you
think do you believe there's a god
for real
um i all jokes aside all jokes aside i
don't believe in what i've been taught i
believe there's definitely a higher
thing going on and a power energy love
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
but i don't believe in the god i was
taught i don't believe in the story i
was taught right i just believe there
definitely is something bigger than us
going on here for sure
i'm not sure what the [ __ ] it is neither
no podcasting has changed my mind from
you know first it was i grew up catholic
so it was god god god and then i had
this whole
you know everyone's dying and i'm just
like i don't know is this
well god's got a plan i'm like well he
clued me in on the [ __ ] thing like
this he just killed two people you know
what i mean like did they not hurt were
they and all that [ __ ] and then i
started struggling and then i would feel
guilty if i didn't pray for all of my
dead relatives and it was a laundry list
every [ __ ] night
and then finally i was like you know
what [ __ ] this i don't believe in it
anymore i don't buy it
and then we had the episode with steve
cantwell where i went from god
struggling with whether this is or isn't
to it isn't to then
like
this salvia trip he talks about in
another parallel universe and i'm like
maybe
all of that isn't even right the yes or
no maybe it's this whole other [ __ ]
thing over here so i all i know is i
don't know yeah but
i know what i feel and think right and
then nobody knows and anybody who claims
they
know
are don't yeah don't listen to your mom
your mom did oh she knows how she feels
yeah she does jesus is real she was
getting convicted about uh you know
lying and so that was why she went
through that but anyway i knew not to
tell anyone at school and i was good and
i was i was a really good child you know
so she meets my stepdad we moved to
atlanta
do you know
uh they were set up through a friend
okay mutual friend not walking up and
down the sidewalk and bunny outfits
no that was when she was a teenager
she's gonna kill me for saying that but
whatever it's great
uh so
she's been uh forgiven so that's an old
janet not the new janet
she's reborn
she loves our son jesus so
where were we at okay so um
my mom meets my step-dad they get
married and she moves us to atlanta
where he lives and you're how old at
this point i am six okay you're still
very young i'm still very young
dad's still around
here or not here but in nashville
and we
you know looking back on it now i'm so
upset that she took us so far away it
was four hours away but still
far away from my dad
and um
but i've i've learned to forgive her now
but
because i wasn't there i don't know what
kind of
danger we were in there i know my dad
was getting in trouble a lot with
drinking and driving and with other
people involved with drugs i don't know
what he was doing but i know there's
stuff i don't know and i'm still asking
people and trying to figure that out
actually before they all die before they
all die yeah yeah
and um so
okay so
christmas another christmas story
i wake up on christmas and
i walk into my mom's room and my stepdad
is con uh you know consoling my mom
she's crying uncontrollably
and i'm like what's wrong what's wrong
what's wrong and
she wouldn't say what's wrong she i
don't know if she couldn't you know
my step-dad wasn't saying anything
and i just kept saying it kept saying it
you know what's wrong mom what's wrong
okay you know you've hated seeing when
you're well
i hated seeing my mom cry hated it
and uh she finally told me what happened
and i just remember
uh
not really understanding you know i
didn't understand what that meant that
death that he was gone permanent and
yeah i literally walked right back out
and started playing with the toys that
were left out for me from santa claus
that morning
on christmas morning you find out your
dad's dead and you're what seven six six
seven i was seven when he died
god what a [ __ ] is christmas just [ __ ]
for you now
yes yes and he actually died
the eve of christmas eve so it was the
23rd
yeah or the early morning of the 23rd
so the 23rd success
yeah christmas eve so the 23rd sucks
the
the 24th sucks and the 25th sucks
because that's when i found out about it
but when i at the time i didn't really
understand it how my brain
dealt with it was oh my god my mom's
gonna die
so
i did not want to be separated from her
right and i'm gonna be alone yep and
everyone around me is gonna die and i'm
gonna be left alone which is
which makes me tear up because i know
that's
literally what you went through
so my biggest fear is actually your life
[Laughter]
i'm glad we're friends
listen can i tell you something
my biggest fear has been my life too
just like you know
mine
um i couldn't go to school my mom was
trying to
my mom was trying to tell me that
the devil was telling me that this is a
lot going on here we got we got chris
santa's not you you know it's funny one
two years you you could have still had
santa for two more years
santa's dad's gone everybody's gone no
wonder you think everybody's gone
i know this sounds crazy but in the
bible belt this does not sound crazy
okay but she
i remember going to this school
counselor when i'm seven years old in
georgia
and this lady writing down in a notebook
right and i'm looking at her and saying
just a picture of this little girl you
know
looking at i'm thinking of stella right
now that age looking at this lady well
the devil's telling me that
that he's gonna kill my mom
so i need to be with her all the time in
case he tries to kill her
and i know he's lying to me
and that god will protect my mom but
the devil's lying to me and can you
imagine a little girl saying that to you
like no
she probably was like okay and i'm like
okay hang on a second somebody come get
this guy's [ __ ] out of my office
exactly
exactly
and to me i was telling the exact truth
because it was what my mom told me you
know yeah the devil is repeating it yeah
the devil comes to steal kill and
destroy he is telling you lies you know
like all of this lucifer's the fallen
angel he's here to you know all these
things so
anyway so i
i cry a lot i'm sad i have migraines the
migraines continue through
six this is going on yeah and migraines
continue all the way up through early
teenager years like 15
i still can't stay on the night
somewhere else without freaking out i
have to call my mom every hour it's
ridiculous or i have to just go home she
would just come get me you know
and it all i didn't understand that it
stemmed from my dad i did not connect it
at the time i just had a child a crazy
crazy [ __ ] i just you know everybody
else was like why do you want to come to
the sleepover and i'm like oh you know
i'll come for a little bit then i gotta
go home with my mom i just
knew she would die if i was away
which that makes no sense i mean if i
was there she would have died but then
i don't know i think maybe because my
dad was away
when he died and i didn't
see him before or after you know can we
talk about that for a second yeah do you
remember the last time you saw your dad
or at least
the last time i remember seeing him was
still in nashville not georgia but she
said he did come with a girlfriend to
georgia once to visit and that we went
to dinner but i don't remember that
uh
so in nashville and i remember him
bringing me and i still had it before
the fire
a little stuffed animal that said guess
who loves you on it
i'm sorry
you just dropped before the fire
when i lost everything
i mean we're going to get to that i
guess
oh my god
hold on
we'll get
to the bottom of the fire yet but he
gave you this little stuffed animal that
had for a really long time and it said
guess who loves you on it so it was
always cool to always have that and it
was the last time i saw him and i
remember hugging him and in the house
and my mom
that my mom has in madison tennessee has
these steep stairs and
mom wouldn't let him come in so we were
just standing on the top of the stairs
and he went to hug me and he kind of was
wobbling i remember my mom like like
grabbing me and pulling me away just
because he was probably a little drunk
and
then he leaves and police off police
come so i don't know
he was just kind of always in
a little trouble i know there was this
awesome judge that would get him out of
trouble
uh he's still friends with papa willie
he actually helped me with my divorce
because my husband and i tried to do
help yourselfdivorce.com but that
doesn't matter
it doesn't work though don't do it
especially when you have three kids
that's what works better your what
worked better your marriage or the
website
we thought it was a good idea we were it
was an amicable split we're like oh this
was only 200 bucks let's do this and
how about we don't hate each other.com
yeah that's a nice one
um okay i want to talk more about your
dad so last time you see him it's this
house is the house by the way i'm asking
that uh your mom still owns yeah yeah so
that house that your father was in you
could still go back in at some point if
you wanted to ever just decide yeah and
so my dad lived in this cabin out in
ridge top tennessee which is close to
where i live now
and i just actually moved
there last year out in this area and
it's where my grandpa's house was when
he lived out in tennessee to
send just an old cabin that's where my
dad was found
he was found hung
so he was um
and that there were some strange things
around it because he was completely
naked which automatically makes everyone
think of
autoerotic asphyxiation which i never
thought about until
mid-20s or something i don't even know
it was a thing until i saw like oprah or
some [ __ ] people were choking themselves
out to come yeah i don't under i don't
understand it you know i've never
been into anything other you know this
regular thing but and my but that's the
thing my mom said that my dad wasn't
either
he was kind of a regular kind of he
wasn't trying to do crazy [ __ ]
um and then he was never naked that's
him in the bedroom no no no
um or not with her anyway and that he
was never naked only in the shower never
in bed even i mean like maybe when they
were [ __ ] i guess but not
you know he would immediately put some
clothes on he wore
long sleeve shirts in the summertime
jeans so it's strange that he was naked
if it was an autoerotic asphyxiation it
may be some sort of humiliation thing i
guess because there were some people he
was running with some sort of motorcycle
crowd
that nobody really knows
quite who they were and it was a new
crowd at the time and uh
we know that my grandpa had sent a lot
of money in for christmas that year and
that was on the table and
at one time and it wasn't there and
there were
liquor bottle bottles shot out
at the house at the house yeah it looked
like there was a party scene you know
um
one of his friends
the first i went i was 18 i walked down
to the willie nelson museum downtown
nashville because i wanted to get a new
bumper sticker because i had a bumper
sticker that said don't believe me i
voted for williamson on it for a long
time that's great that's great
and i got into a car accident and had
another car and wanted to get another
one for this car so i walked down there
and this guy who was my dad's friend was
there
and he was like hey raelynn hey you
wanna know how your dad died he was
hanging up socks in the
in the uh he says it like this
immediately and i was like wait who are
you what you know
because i'd walk down in there he
immediately recognized me i was i didn't
not know who he was
and he gave me this kind of weird story
about how he um which is true my dad did
like to tie news i told you he was this
cowboy guy right and it was the thing
back then and very he loved texas and
that kind of looks so
he was tying new he loved tying nooses
he so his story was that he had tied a
noose
put it on his neck does this make any
like it's so stupid and then you naked
by the way oh yeah remember we make it
so i'm just going to try this just my
new my new knot out real quick yeah yeah
and then
uh hang was trying to hang his socks up
in the loft and falls it was the most
ridiculous thing miraculously the rope
just wraps around and catches and holds
a grown man yeah like that's not that's
not happening nothing makes sense either
he went up there and put himself up
there or somebody put him up there
that's it yeah there's no accidental
fall and a rope's gonna snag and catch
and choke you naked yeah
and um i don't
i know there was some talk about but
like everything was cleaned up really
quickly you know because they just
thought it was suicide so they didn't
even consider it being anything else
do you or is there any thought from
anyone in the family that he was a
target because of who he was
simply that i don't even bring it up to
my family um
your grandfather and [ __ ] like that
i i don't know i mean that sucks you
don't even you can't bring it up or
don't because that's your dad like
forget that that's willie nelson's son
and all that that's still whatever all
that stripped away that's your father
like i you know you have a right to know
i will say that my
dad's friends have said that my dad
would get really low and really really
drunk and that it was possible but i
just feel like there would have been
some sort of closure there if he had a
plan to do it so i don't mean like a
note or something you think he would
have definitely let someone know yeah
there would i feel like are you close to
your grandfather were they close like a
father son yeah yeah i mean you're on
the bus and everything you physically
close yeah and it's i don't even bring
my dad up to my grandpa i let my grandpa
do that
you know does he do does he ever talk
about how does that feel when he talks
about i mean because that's i'm just
like i'm getting emotional now thinking
like oh my god if
stella was gone but i'm just talking to
her daughter like our son i'm like oh
god yeah how do you do that you know
that's the thing is cause every time i
would see him i could see pain and
sadness in his eyes
and also when i saw him it made me sad
because my dad
he reminds me of my dad you know
it smells like my dad around him
um my dad would play the guitar to me my
dad would uh had a lot of his cadence a
great song you could listen to is my
body it's just a suitcase for my can you
believe this my body's just a suitcase
for my soul he did this song with my
grandpa now the video was done in the
80s
early 90s i think
oh
he was he died in 91 so it had to be
late 80s and it's a weird video but he
you can tell he has a cadence of him and
singing and stuff
so you know it's
the same thing and i could never really
tell them but i did write a song the
only sad song that we wrote was daddy's
grave and we can't we don't even do it
at shows cause it makes everyone so sad
it makes me sad you know
it takes three songs to get people
dancing again and you know we're trying
to have fun and you know
we want people to leave happy not sad
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor ritual we
deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies and why especially when it
comes to something that we take every
day rituals clean vegan friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients and bioavailable forms
your body can actually use and what you
won't find are sugars gmos major
allergens synthetic fillers and
artificial colorants plus the fresh
taste and delayed release capsule design
makes taking your vitamins easy look i
take ritual every day
um i've got them on order they get
delivered right to my mailbox and i
while i still can't taste that much i
can absolutely taste the minty uh
freshness in my ritual daily vitamins
all right i was looking for something
that didn't have salt dust and you know
table salt and everything else in the
damn thing and ritual is the best i'm
telling you it's a multivitamin and it
should contain key nutrients in the form
your body can actually use to help fill
gaps in the diet there's no shady extras
all right rituals delayed release
capsule design delivers high quality
nutrients including vitamin d3 and just
two daily pills rituals made traceable
so you always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain it's now available for women men
and teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different stages in life ritual makes
healthy habits easy your multivitamins
are delivered to your door like i said
every month with free shipping always
you can start snooze or cancel your
subscription anytime and if you don't
love ritual within your first month
they'll refund your first order all
right get key nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com
honeydew to start your ritual today our
next sponsor is raycon no matter how
you're feeling about getting back out
there there's no denying it's an
adjustment so when the world gets too
loud something i love to do is create my
own soundtrack by popping in my raycon
wireless earbuds sometimes you need some
upbeat music to pump you up before you
see people or to stay calm with some
guided meditation all right uh first of
all you know i'm listening to the
honeydew on my raikons but i've been
walking a lot of it walking these parks
a lot lately getting outside losing
weight and i just hit playlist and i
listen to anything that makes me feel
good i'm out there thinking about you
know positivity and how great uh life is
right now man and my raycons take me
there okay uh and raycons are the best
way to listen they come
they've got the like a bunch of gel tips
for your comfort and unlike some other
brands they don't stick out of your ears
okay raycons have a 32-hour battery life
so you can listen to what you want when
you want for a really long time they
start at half the price of other premium
audio brands but they sound just as good
and raycon's come with a 45 day
happiness guarantee so you really can't
lose give them a try you'll see what i
mean all right create your own
soundtrack right now with raycon
honeydew listeners can get 15 off your
raycon order at buy raycon dot com slash
honeydew that's by raycon dot com slash
honeydew to save 15
on ray cons by raycon.com honeydew our
next sponsor is babel when you're
traveling to a destination where you
don't know the language it can be
challenging to accomplish even the
simplest of tasks all right uh i was in
mexico recently i think it was march
april somewhere in there and um i took
spanish class in like eighth grade you
know what i mean and i still remember
things like cockahuates you know some of
the stuff stands out zapatos calcitines
things like that uh but i would hear a
word here a word there you know segura
speaks fluent spanish my daughter's
starting to learn already and i was like
man i gotta learn this so i had actually
subscribed to babel before babel came on
board as a matter of fact and i am a
happy customer i'm taking my spanish
every day
uh i really like it they give you these
like um
reviews because once you do it and then
you review it you know at least for me
it helps you learn more all right so
thankfully babel is out there they are
the number one selling language learning
app through babel's bite-sized lessons
you'll learn new language skills you can
actually use in the real world from
greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel is a travel essential all
right babel's 15 minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a new language
on the go other language learning apps
use ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts and their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and your accent there are so many ways
to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can get access podcasts
games videos stories and even live
classes start your new language learning
journey today with babel all right right
now when you purchase a three month
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use promo code
honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babel language for life
now let's get back to the do
but uh i was able to write that song and
get a lot of things out that was
um that brought some healing through the
family because i was able to see i did
perform it at a show shows for a while
and he got to see me do it
and afterwards he came he said i just
want you to know your dad would be
really proud of you man and that was
probably the best moment right
i had a bittersweet moment where um
i was back in maryland for just vacation
and tom was coming in to um
do baltimore the day i was leaving he's
like ryan you can't leave and i had
stella and i was like i dude i got we've
been here for i can't remember how many
days like i gotta get back he's like you
can't you can't miss this i'm doing the
[ __ ] model the lyric is what it was
called and
um back and that's like a bucket list
theater if you want to perform in
baltimore you know and i was like [ __ ] i
go all right 10 things need to line up
but if i can get them done it's
happening and they all did
and i got to do that theater and then
one of my best friends from back home
shannon came up to me and he knew my dad
and my grandma so well and he's like
your dad and grandma would be so [ __ ]
proud and i was just like oh
and that's like
like i love what i do
but i also hate that the people i love
and who are really responsible for me
being here don't even get to [ __ ]
see it or hear it or feel it or you know
touch it taste it none of it you don't
think they're watching somewhere what do
you think i mean it depends on what
unity or do you think it's reincarnation
what if they're not even my parents i
might be in this universe over here i
don't know
um do i think that listen
i this is what i think i think that
these people literally died for me um
they were the best people in my life
and
i owe it to them like i can't this
podcast they're alive because of my
comedy they stay alive in my world like
my daughter can go listen to
a ton of [ __ ] about her grandfather and
great-grandmother and all that stuff so
i really like the fact that there are
these archives posteriority yeah that
are here and stay i think we make it we
make a real difference on this show i
think i agree um
so
um i believe they're present you know
i'm a big 11 11 is a big number for me
and
every time i see it i just
i mean i went home to i was back home
doing a show and i
you know i don't drink a ton but this
one night i just tied one on and my
buddy took me to my grandmom's house and
she had
in baltimore they have the brick row
homes it's just this little white like
almost like a paint stripe and it's got
the numbers going up like one one one
one
and uh i'm sitting there just looking at
it in front of her house and she had
died and we got kicked out and all this
[ __ ] and i he had a shovel a little like
military shovel on the back of his jeep
and i ran up to that [ __ ] house i
don't know who lived there and i i had
my feet on that wall and i was prying
that [ __ ] out of that [ __ ] wall and i
got it and i [ __ ] took it to my place
you were at my place it's above my front
door leave and i repainted it and
touched it up nice and that's my little
touching on the way into the stadium you
know what i mean yeah yeah that's little
[ __ ] i do
so i believe they're here but i believe
they're here because i've
kept them alive
through my
art comedy whatever so i feel their
presence non-stop so that's why i feel
like yes to answer that question yeah
you know
um my dad i know he
hated
star [ __ ]
that were just around just because of
that right my grandpa yeah
uh gold digging ladies you know he hated
he could see him coming from a mile away
he
hated it so
i know that had to be hard trying to
spend time with your dad
and also i know he was really proud of
papa willie i know that you know
of course
but
yeah so it's just sad i guess it was
it's very your dad's gonna live a life
that no one else is you know what i mean
like very few people live a life like
that i'm sure that's crazy difficult
also with all the [ __ ]
success and greatness that comes with it
is that the [ __ ] leeches and the
scumbags and the thieves and roaches and
[ __ ]
and a 16 that's happening to him
i mean i think about my life at 16 and
we're gonna ask you about that at the
end
um but i'm parentless
and your dad's the opposite but
man what's coming in his way with the
drugs and everything all that [ __ ] how
are you gonna keep a 16 year old clean
and sober
you know that's the age where you want
to start [ __ ] drinking doing all of
it you got it
all right there
yeah all of it right there god
yeah and not much adult supervision
and it was the 80s too i mean late 70s
80s you know that's some hard drugs that
were coming out that people didn't
understand that they were bad you know
they just thought
it was like weed did you know there was
something like called caffeine water now
no no no no then like when speed was a
big thing they would put caffeine in
water apparently there were just cases
of that around the
uh the crew the family and the crew you
know richard pryor's got one of the best
jokes about he's just one of these quiet
ones
so good but he's like he's talking about
people like a junkie in his family or an
uncle or something he's like man i ain't
addicted to cocaine i've been doing this
[ __ ] for 20 years
you know what i mean like what do you
mean i know that's just what i do i
ain't addicted to this with what i do
microdose code yeah
[Laughter]
i've never done cocaine and i never want
to just because i know what my dad you
know just some stories that my dad might
he there's some cool stories about my
dad like
because he was willie nelson's son
he i remember he wanted to get a story
goes that he wanted to get a six-pack
and the gas station was closed so he
just drove his truck into it into the
gas station broke the glass yeah yeah
got out
grabbed the six-pack just the six-pack
laid money down for the six-pack got in
his truck and left
and just
you know it was a small town everybody
knew it was him and knew that but like
what would you do if you were 16 17 and
you had that lifestyle you're just it's
not even real it's not even yeah i don't
i don't understand it i didn't get that
my mom kept me very sheltered so i had
to say my normal life you know it was
different that i would go see my grandpa
you know was your mom and her family um
were they musical
musicians at all no not at all nobody on
my mom's side what um do you feel
obligated to be a musician because of
and was your dad your dad you said play
guitar but did he actually perform and
stuff too or was he just you know
musically inclined yeah he tried in
nashville but they told him
no which
my grandpa they told my grandpa now yeah
and then he got out of nashville and i
told you this is why i relate to like i
love the outlaw country [ __ ] i love that
nashville told all these guys no and
they were like all right well then [ __ ]
you and they went and [ __ ] did it
themselves their way took a lot longer
and i really relate to that [ __ ] you
know yeah that's why it's called outlaw
country because the you know the people
who are running things are saying
this isn't going to work you know no you
sound like to my grandpa your voice is
crap
we like your songs but and you play
great but no
and uh he was like well i'll just go and
found some guys in new york and
they did red-headed stranger then and
they let him do his thing what's your
favorite willie nelson
song oh
i love still is still moving to me you
know that one
i love that one i like always on my mind
oh yeah it kills me he didn't write that
one though that's okay it's still he
sings the [ __ ] out of him yeah yeah yeah
he did make it popular and elvis tried
oh really yeah i didn't know that and
there was a i bet he's got great i'm the
stories he must [ __ ] have are you
gonna have him on your podcast
my grandpa i don't ask him to do
anything because he does so much and i
just don't want to bother him he's 88.
like shouldn't you just live your life
and do what you want he's going to and
be left alone and i try not to bother
him we shouldn't smoke
uh so
i'm glad we smoked wheat that was a lot
of fun
yeah i was gonna say you don't do
cocaine or anything but yeah certainly i
smoked plenty of weed this weekend i'll
do one hits all day long i'd like to
micro dose wheat but here in california
when you can just buy
dog walkers dog walkers best i smoke dog
walkers all day long out around the
block just
you know rip three of i call them
just take a joint you know what i mean
like i don't know why
i'm smoking three of these [ __ ]
call them little doggies
[Laughter]
we're gonna get a couple minutes
remember i saw the first day and a half
i was here there were two homeless
people i was like what is this
all all you comedians in l.a it's all on
your podcast oh the homeless is so bad
it's so bad it's so bad i saw two and i
get to your house i'm like ryan what is
this why are y'all trying to lie to
people and say that there's homeless
people here
and you're like no you just didn't go to
the right spot the next day
went to the right spot because it's just
ten after ten after ten after ten like
okay well i guess you're right
yeah it's pretty wild it's pretty bad
it's [ __ ] bad
um
what are you gonna do about that i'm not
gonna do anything we'll talk to
councilwoman lawn and gretty about that
[ __ ] though yeah yeah yeah um
so
okay
um
we talked about your favorite song i
want to talk a little more about like
you know let's talk about getting
married like
you lost your dad early
so who was who would you say was your
stepfather a male role model in your
life or not really like that we weren't
that tight then but he's always been
good to me you know and
good to my mom which is most important
and accepted me as his own and when he
didn't have to you know
just because he loved her and
he's
i i love hanging out with him now he's
one of my best friends now and he's all
good he's at my house in nashville right
now fixing our band van you know oh
that's awesome so you know i teased
about not having a dad but he but also
he mellowed out in the last 10 years
before that he was very
stressed out about money or just making
sure we everything was done right and we
went to church and
just strict you know when but all of his
kids are grown up and he's very close to
retirement age
he's just mellowed out discuss it kind
of is what happens
in your old age
hopefully don't you just want to chill
on the way out
yeah yeah and i guess you learned that
it kind of just
taking it as it comes is easier than
trying to manage micromanagement every
older you get you can reflect on your
experience and be like okay i've been
through some horrible [ __ ] this ain't
that bad we just we just rear-ended
somebody and everybody's okay who gives
a [ __ ] you know what i mean like
whatever i stress about less uh these
days with that kind of [ __ ] yeah i get
worried that i'm gonna have to pee
really bad and then that situation
happens and then you're stuck there
having to pee
and then they come and get you and
you're like listen listen i really got
peed after we hit this this accident
didn't make me piss myself i peed after
a hit only because i had to go like that
she feed herself like poor lady hit this
guy so hard she pissed herself like no i
did it
i had to go every single time i have to
pee in traffic i think i'm like great
this is the time i'm gonna get stuck in
traffic have you peed in your car before
yeah a ton of times i did it five i
think five or six times over covid
because everything was shut down keep
that little potty like a little portable
toilet in the back for stella
and so she could just sit and pee in a
little bag and i just got the whole
hatch hatchback and we just shut it and
she just sits in there and pees in it
but there's times where i'm like i'm
driving from here to pasadena and in the
old days when it took you an hour and a
half i wouldn't i pull over i'd climb in
the back seat and just pee in the back
pee at her pee
[Laughter]
i can't piss myself before the show i
don't have another pair of pants you
know what i mean i'm driving to perform
i can't piss or [ __ ] myself you have to
pee in her thing
i pee in the pee bag yeah
i get the back i climb in the back and i
do it people see me coming out of the
back of the car and i'm the only one
exiting the vehicle what the [ __ ] this
guy doing
and when do you get rid of the peed is
it just a 30 dude get rid of it right
there rubber floor mats i tie it up
tight it doesn't leak i leave it on a
rubber floor mat and then when i get to
a trash can or a dumpster i deposit it
properly yeah hey when i was driving uh
this when i was driving jb to the
airport today
this girl threw panties outside of on
the 110 outside
i am not like
he goes what was that i was like that
was panties he goes panties
panties
pink paint why would somebody do that
what's the point
i don't know
i mean maybe they just maybe they were
how was that getting those like little
thongs they couldn't be taking up that
much room in there did it have to go out
yeah like out there what did you get on
there that you needed to get it out
quick
because it smelled bad maybe did you
[ __ ] but i got a feeling like if your
panties smell bad
everything else still smells like
honestly you didn't solve the problem
you just relocated it
oh my god okay california
let me reset us here because i want to
talk you lobbed this [ __ ] uh
comment out about a fire what talk about
okay you said i lost everything i mean
it was just a few years ago
so uh it was new year's day so it was
not new year's eve right so that
christmas holiday season listen i want
you to know from me too
my father died at during the
thanksgiving time and so thanksgiving
and christmas for me
is [ __ ] like i'm glad i have stella to
make christmas exciting because
it's just you know you know exactly how
it is for me yeah do you guys have
seasons here does it change in the fall
well i mean we you know they tell us
when it's fall okay
like fall today like all right y'all
don't have leaves falling around there's
no leaves changing and [ __ ] here well
that happens in nashville right yeah
it's beautiful and well whenever that
starts to happen i mean like as soon as
it's
overcast for four or five days in a row
and then those leaves start changing
that feeling
i won't say depressed because it's i
refuse to be depressed you just you have
to just
uh what i've learned is consume your
life with laughter and make everything
funny you know
in order to get through this
whatever this [ __ ] is right
but uh
as soon as fall hits
i'll feel that gloom start coming on and
i'll just get like a little bit kind of
like when you're about to start your
period you know just a little bit [ __ ]
and
i and i have to remember oh
it's fall and this is what happens and i
have to reset you know just reset
and be like nope this you know why this
is this way
it's just this poor little girl inside
that still like what happened to my dad
why didn't he come back you know and not
understanding i still don't understand
where he is
i don't get it i used to i remember sit
there thinking like what is this how are
we able to do this what is inside of me
what is me where did my dad go it until
it scared me so much that i was like
i gotta watch sesame street you know
you're so young
those are questions from six
not supposed to be
i know but i remember i would think
about it so hard and be like what is it
scare me it still kind of scares me what
is this you know how are you you talking
to me right now and
and you can feel this energy you know
you feel energy like what is that what
it you know so as a child like that
you're getting this anxiety's just oh
yeah uh and it it uh physically came out
through headaches
and um i would throw up when i would
have these migraines and stuff
and then finally my mom was like i think
you need to talk about what's going on
and finally i would just kind of
open up to her and say
i'm scared you're going to die i want to
stay right i couldn't say that to her
but that's when i finally did we figured
it out
the headache stopped you know and
the headache stopped i still didn't want
to go spend the night
only very few times did i even have to
because she would go out of town or
something with my stepdad
but uh it all got better but so
wait how did we get when we were talking
about the fire yeah how did we get here
i don't know where you went but i'm
still waiting here here we go i'm gonna
get there
i'm still
okay so this is just four years ago
2016
and it's new year's day that's why
that's the whole christmas and then we
went back into when i was a kid okay
thank god it was you who did that that
was me
okay so 2016 i go to sleep that night
the kids um
are in bed and real quick you have how
many children
um let me back up a little bit
so i have twin boys they are 14 now
and i have a little girl that is
11. okay
so
i got married when i was very young
because my mom didn't want me living
with my boyfriend out of wedlock that's
literally why i got married i didn't
want her to be disappointed you know
but um got got pregnant pretty quickly
and not on purpose it just happened
and then he uh has
10 sets of identical twins in his family
no way yeah anybody didn't know [ __ ]
sets he and he supposedly didn't know
how the hell do you not know 10 seconds
you're supposed to tell somebody that
before you get them
uh so anyway uh we got
the best ones and um and by the way
we co-parent really well and it was an
amicable split and his uh wife and i was
totally awesome i told you i think i
prayed for her because she she meets all
the things i was like please let him
find someone with big boobs big butt she
loves football she likes to cook and
stay home she hates seeing she doesn't
want to be in front of anyone
and that's and she loves my kids yeah
and that is her and your mom prayed for
a man and you prayed for a [ __ ]
stepmother
the lord works in a mysterious way
and you know him and i have talked about
it we're like we were just so spiteful
to each other that we can't
there's no way we could ever be more
than just friends but we do co-parent
our kids together and there's it's not
perfect but you know it's we try our
best okay so he's living uh like not
even a mile away i'm living uh in the
house i go to sleep the kids are up with
me
and in the middle of the night i kind of
wake up and i can see reflections of
fire on my bedroom wall
and i'm like what
is that fire you know and i get up and i
look down the hallway and my daughter's
room is in flames holy [ __ ] and there's
no smoke detectors going off or anything
i had taken them down to paint and did
not put them back up no
oh my god how did i wake up i have no
idea so i run into her room and ran
through the fire i didn't feel any burns
on my feet
didn't feel anything on my feet until
like an hour later okay but ran through
the fire burnt my feet uh my daughter's
not in there i'm looking around and i
scream vivian and she yells at me from
my room
and i run to my room on the way i stop
and yell in the boys room boys get up
the house is on fire
i'm yelling screaming go get her she's
pretty young at the time so this was in
2016 so she was 2009.
she was under 10. you know she's like
six or seven the boys are like nine
and um so i grab her i pick her up
grab my lap it's the strangest things
you grab at these moments right grab my
laptop
and
run out the boys are right behind me i
get them out to the deck i'm like you
guys stay right here my sister is living
down in the mother-in-law suite of this
house with her roommate and i'm
screaming at them they're coming the
cats i could see two cats running my
sister gets the dog and i'm like oh i
need to get my wallet
never never ever ever ever ever go back
into a house that's on fire ever ever i
knew this but like how bad is it now is
it like is all i could see was um
smoke and are you not yet it hadn't
filled with smoke yet because i got
stuck in that so i go back in and all of
a sudden i mean it wasn't very long i'm
back the hallway kind of did this tea
thing you know so i go and all of a
sudden i'm running into walls and can't
see anything it was just like that
and i was like oh [ __ ] where am i you
know and i remember being a little kid
at davidson academy in nashville
tennessee and the firemen comes in to
tell you about safety and fires and all
this and he said if you ever get caught
in smoke get low right and i remembered
that in that moment so i got low i had
my phone with me because i was on the
phone with the fire department anyway or
the dispatch of 9-1-1
so i pull
instinctively pull my phone out flip up
the iphone thing hit my flashlight
because you think if you're if you can't
see something you hit your flashlight on
your phone right i do that and pull up
and thank god in front of me was my
guest bedroom
like a spare room i wasn't even going
for that by the way it was opposite way
and you didn't know why you really
didn't know that right i was trying to
go to my room to get my money because i
was like i gotta get my money
and so
uh it's weird these things that you
wanna did not think about grabbing my
guitar or weed or
cigarettes i would just stand near your
house
[Laughter]
but then yeah i couldn't breathe in
there then i realized i couldn't breathe
i see the bed bed spread i realized
where i was
it happened at like 1 15. [ __ ] so
everybody's asleep everyone's asleep
yeah i
like six months
when we moved back like a year later the
neighbor who lived next door she was
like yeah we saw your house on fire just
flames we were like oh no i'm like why
the [ __ ] did you not call somebody crazy
lady anyway we don't live there
you're good by the guest bedroom i see
that we're in the spare bedroom i i'm
like okay i know where i am i can crawl
myself out and i did i called myself and
just start coughing like crazy
so uh
get out we all get out to the van we
um luckily i parked my van in the garage
and kept the keys in it so it was the
furthest thing away from where the fire
happened
and we uh just go and watch it burn and
then
watch the firemen try to
save it so everything with smoke damage
water damage or burnt gone
and uh
so it's what people don't you don't
realize that even if the fire makes it
that water [ __ ] they're powering on it's
probably gonna ruin your [ __ ] anyway no
and smoke damage terrible so
and a funny thing is a friend of mine
had kept her
she lost her dad to suicide
too and she had kept a lot of her stuff
at my house i don't mean a lot but she
lost a lot of that stuff in the fire
right
i did too by the way i lost all my [ __ ]
but she was on this netflix show i will
not say what it is but in this netflix
show she keeps talking about this that
she lost her dad's stuff that she lost
to a fire and it was like the
sympathetic getting all this sympathy
for him like
that's my [ __ ] fire you're talking
your house my house
and by the way oh we lived you know and
my kids getting them out and the animals
and
my dad's stuff too by the way and all of
my [ __ ] yeah you lost that little
stuffed bear or was it a bear it was
like a mouse it was a pink mouse i don't
know where he got that burned up it's
probably like the dollar store or
something
yeah everything pretty much burned up my
mom's wedding dress that i had i was
gonna say what do you miss the most
what's the if you if right now if you
could have one thing you know that those
favorite pair of jeans it's that you
know yeah i lost my favorite pair of
jeans tv and all the other [ __ ] yeah
favorite pair of jeans shorts too i
remember those and
um
the radio station shirt that my mom had
from where she met my dad like little
yeah
but honestly personal keepsake stuff
here's something cool after that
happened
when a fire happens you know
everything's gone but your insurance
covers everything and then you get to
start again and it was almost this like
this was the house that i lived in with
my husband and now i get to pick a whole
different house because they just redid
it all and i sold that house and made
money on it and even after it was burned
no after they fixed it okay
i was like who the [ __ ] bought it
out of the house
for over asking price
willie nelson's
no
um but uh yeah so anyway
i'm not in there anymore but that's the
fire story and i actually put out a i
called i've
called iphone and thanks them for saving
my life for having that flashlight on
there and the lady customer service lady
was like well okay
we don't get these kind of calls
i was like well is there a what's the
best way to should i just make a video
and put it on youtube and tag it she
goes yeah
maybe you'll write a letter
i don't sh i was like
who's writing letters nobody's writing
like i was writing letters no
but yeah so uh the iphone i can oh my
life to the iphone flashlight you really
believed that if you didn't have that
flashlight you're not fine i wouldn't
have seen it i wouldn't have seen where
i was wow
because you thought you were i thought
it was in the hallway still
that's scary as [ __ ] and you got all the
animals out every everybody was okay
material stuff
does not matter it really you find out
what started the fire a lamp caused the
fire of my mom back to my mom she had
this hot pink 80s lamp that had been in
a closet and she gave it to my daughter
because my daughter loved pink
and
that night i mean my son even came and
asked me hey mom is it okay if i turn on
this lamp for viv and i'm like yeah it's
fine thanks for asking
and it was left on and i think she
jumped down
from bed in the middle of the night
because i thought she was in her room
and i think when she ran across the
floor to me that it jostled the lamp in
some way and it fell over she probably
she might have seen it fall over in the
middle night but she was sick she was
still his age you know just half asleep
because she would get gotten in bed with
me thank goodness and i think that's
happened or the cats couldn't knock the
lamp off either way the lamp falls off
it breaks the light bulb it's just an
old lamp and there was a towel laying
right there that led right to the wood
door that and then
i'm just glad i woke up right because
yeah the stories are here smoke
detectors your whole all of you could
have died i have a little bit of and
i have all kinds of respect for people
who have been in war and have real ptsd
so i'm using that phrase very lightly i
just don't know how better it is to say
it but i feel like i have a little bit
of ptsd from that night because i can't
go to sleep without listening to a
comedy podcast for real every night
every night because i think about that
night and any little thing that could
have gone wrong
what if it what if the spare bedroom
wasn't in front of me it was something
or just you know i didn't notice where i
was i would have died what if i didn't
get the boys out or get fit i mean all
any any bad scenario of that night pops
into my head
or what if the smoke alarm doesn't work
tonight you know
just so i just have to have my brain on
something else to fall asleep and the
podcasts are the best way so i'm not
watching something necessarily you know
and it keeps your brain on something
light and fun
so you co-parent well now yes and
does your daughter does your daughter
know she might have done the may uh burn
the house down she doesn't
don't tell her
we'll fast forward through this part
y'all put a little something up on the
screen
no she'll be fine she'll be fine
man that's terrible so
the cool thing is you get to rebuild i
was i get i get what you're saying like
this wasn't even my [ __ ] this was and
now boom you get to restart and rebuild
and do it your way he was a university
of tennessee fan so the entire rec room
was ut orange do you know what ut orange
looks like it's so bad the entire room
this was a 985 square foot room
neon
orange is his big titty football fan new
wife uh tennessee fan you wouldn't
believe she has a christmas tree
dedicated to
ut is it orange or like white no it's
white with orange ornaments all the
ornaments
yes
she named their dog
neely after neely stadium which is where
they play
i'm telling you she's the perfect one
for him
perfect he always loved like big tits
and big butts and stuff and i was always
trying to get skinny you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
so i'm telling you they were meant to be
they're meant to be but any time we get
together i mean we all we'll have family
dinners all together sometimes and
that's nice yeah yeah and the kids
really love it when we all get together
and hang out
and they like his his wife they love her
yeah how do you feel how did you feel
about that at first were you okay with
that i loved her there were he had a
couple of relationships before that they
were not nice
one of them actually showed up at one of
my shows with
a friend and i don't think she knew i
was playing at the five spot she just
happened to be there because it's a
trendy spot
and then
after the show i went up and i was like
what'd you think and she goes i really
liked that rebecca girl that's saying
right to my face
right to my face and that's when i knew
oh
you've been fake when we've been talking
every time before because that was the
first time i'd seen her out without the
kids or scott being right there
so then from then on it was just kind of
i was just i didn't talk to her and but
this one you like and then the first one
didn't really
she
my boy said that she not that maybe that
that she'd liked my daughter more than
them and that bothered me so
she's not okay in my book
that was the other one so i started i
really did i started praying like i i
need for me to be okay with
all of this i i need this perfect woman
letter and i just started i want to have
big boobs big butt i want her happy
blonde you know southern girl i mean she
is she's everything wants to cook out
all the time and do yard work
i'm down for the cookout but you could
have i'll cut your grass on a ride mower
that's it god loves yard work i don't
get it but uh yeah it's not the life
that i necessarily i wanted to go play
music
and
i always have wanted to go play music
and anytime i'd bring it up he'd be like
you know
and um
the beginning of the end of that was the
night that he told me that i couldn't
wear a midriff shirt and i was like wait
a minute i'm an adult and i can't and my
dad's dead i can and my dad's dead
i have one dad he's dead you're not
allowed to tell me
i can't wear a midriff shirt
and uh and i didn't you know because i
didn't when i started thinking like i
don't want to live my life
worried about somebody else's feelings
well that's control you know [ __ ] that
too like [ __ ] your feelings you're also
like i'm not living under your control
what are you talking about yeah and i
know that he he's probably he doesn't do
that to her now i don't think you know
but she doesn't want to wear crop tops
either
well those big titties aren't gonna you
know come out of that crowd she don't
need crop tops she's got big titties
those titties will pull that shirt up
you're gonna see her belly
oh that's great i did make him get a
vasectomy
before we go
hold on a minute oh god accident well
you know i knew i was on my way out but
you know he definitely
got the vasectomy i i
maybe i should have
well it was the plan you know and i was
already kind of trying
uh we were already in therapy and when i
went to
thank god she didn't throw me under the
bus but the therapist i looked her i was
like i need out of this i need you to
help
this and she said you know when you were
19.
hold on i might have just thrown myself
under the bus
[Laughter]
and then he goes in and then you go in
together you try to have it like this oh
yeah
let's bro down here come connect with me
you know look at my i do not want to be
married anymore please help me get out
of this what's the right way we have
kids i want to be i didn't because i
didn't want any fighting you know you're
not in there saying he's a piece of [ __ ]
sure and she said
when you were 19 and you got married
nobody you didn't go through counseling
for someone to walk you through if you
should or not shouldn't get married but
now you have me so let me walk you
through
should or shouldn't you get divorced
and that made sense you know so i was
like okay so then i was like i'll listen
you know but then we did and i was like
i still want help
i'm not okay without wearing crop tops
yeah i mean and there was more than that
but you know i wanted to do music i
wanted to
do more than just be at home being at
home i i couldn't just be at home all
the time anymore i just quit nursing the
babies you know i was like i can get out
a little bit more
yeah but i also homeschool my kids
too
yeah the whole time you have
my boys went to kindergarten
and actually went to college for
elementary education so it's not you
know we're not like just watching sesame
street for
school but
they went to kindergarten and then the
next year
we started homeschooling we found a
program called classical conversations
and it basically teaches them through
song
every subject
and we connect with that and you meet
with the community once a week so it's
kind of school but once a week school
meet with the tutor learn the stuff go
back
so i've been able to
basically the kids and i've grown up
together is how it's been and i remember
looking when
when uh it's interesting can i say this
like it's your dad grew up with his dad
in a different environment on a bus and
sort of like you've kept your kids
around you the same way
do you think yeah that part of your
trauma
is
home school keeping your kids around
because you're scared like you were your
mom that they're gonna go no i yeah i
don't want them to leave the nest i'll
leave the nest and they stay at the
house all the time so i can know that
they're safe you know i
now my biggest fear is losing them i'm
your dad you know yes yes you
[Music]
i've seen you and i know you're a good
dad that is what a good dad is that
means a lot thank you very much and my
stepdad's great i just loved you i got
pictures of you guys hanging out
together the other night she asked about
you good yeah i'll see her before i
leave again
um
where are we at
um
we're just about wrapped up to be honest
because i want to ask you going back to
everything we've talked about now
what advice you would give your 16 year
old self
oh don't get married in three years
that is it don't get married wait till
after you're 35 to get married well i
mean because you can still have babies
why it's just we're
we we can own property yeah i went
through this with you today i'm a woman
i can own property
i can um vote
i don't need a husband i don't need a
man i can i am my own husband i can do
it i have youtube videos that show me
how to do [ __ ] you don't need parents
you don't need husbands
you got youtube
i got youtube songs the internet's
working yeah i wish i had youtube when i
didn't have parents
i did learn how to tie a tie on youtube
yeah yeah well i don't have a dad to ask
how to tie a tie you know [ __ ] like that
like i had a friend ask me he's like who
taught you how to like have a good steak
i was like
nobody
who taught you how to i was like you
just gotta go in and and they tell you
how to you should have it cooked and
then you learn like oh this is how
people like steak i was like nobody
who taught you how to grow nobody they
tell you nobody though just like trial
and error you just did everything on
your own like everyone else that would
learn how to do [ __ ] that didn't have
somebody to show it to them like what do
you mean how did i learn how to do this
you just learn
i mean if you want i can grill
yeah
it's you're an amazing person though
most people like you should be angry and
mean and you know just bitter and i'm
listen i'm not this person all the
[ __ ] time i'm not overall an angry
bitter person no i'm not
i was in my 20s i was i wouldn't say i
was bitter but i was definitely [ __ ]
angry yeah and i still have a chip on my
shoulder it'll never go away i don't i
won't let it go away i it's it's what's
it's what's okay your biggest fear in
life is my life
that chip on my shoulder has been what's
protected me and got me to where i am so
i know that it's not
the best thing to have so i have to find
this
balance of like all right you got to let
some [ __ ] go and you got to be cool
about some [ __ ] you got to change about
some [ __ ] but also there's a reason
you're here and why you're here and
don't forget where the [ __ ] you come
from you know what i mean because look
we
you hear these people talk about like
they were poor and then they were rich
and then right back down you know what i
mean like it life is
not one thing and yeah i don't know it
it's been opened my
that's my car alarm
um
thank you thank you for doing this
thank you for being here you're the best
um will you please we're going to the
comedy store tonight yeah okay um will
you again plug everything you want to
play please music is funny podcast which
ryan is a guest on so go check that one
out and uh it's musicians talking to
comedians about music and comedy check
out raylen nelson band
thanks
thank you you're the best this is
awesome thank you so much uh as always
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you